DALLAS TAYLOR: Did you know
that there's no sound in space ?
LORI GLAZE: You don't
have sound in space
because sound
requires molecules.
You have to be able to move the
molecules with the sound waves.
And without the molecules there,
the sound just doesn't move.
You can try and use your
lungs to push the sound out
of your mouth, but it
won't travel anywhere.
DALLAS TAYLOR: But there might
be sound on other planets.
We talked with scientists
at NASA's Goddard space
Flight Center to find
out what it would sound
like on the surface of Venus.
LORI GLAZE: In my
mind, what sound
would be like on the surface,
because you have this really
dense atmosphere, much denser
than Earth's, the sound
would be more like, or tend
toward what things sound
like when you're underwater.
If you could imagine something
in between air and water,
that kind of density,
you're running your hands
through that, and
you would feel that.
KEITH NOLL: One thing
we do know about Venus
is that it has lighting,
so you might hear thunder.
DALLAS TAYLOR: I wonder what
other things, like my voice
might sound like.
I'm on Venus, in
this ethereal world
that's a mix between a
gas-like atmosphere and water.
I'm almost floating.
But yet, it's not as restrictive
as being submerged in water.
My voice, the thunder,
it's all slightly
muffled and distorted
as it travels
through the thick atmosphere.
Of course, this is
all just conjecture.
There's no way to
truly know what
it would sound like
on other planets
without recording them with
some sort of microphone.
So what does the future
hold for us to truly
be able to test our sound
theories on other planets?
SCOTT GUZEWICH: There's
going to be a microphone
on the next Mars Rover.
The rover launched
in 2020 is supposed
to have a microphone on it.
We expect that it'll hear
a few different things.
The sound as the rover
drives across the surface,
for example, you know,
will be transmitted
both through the atmosphere
and through the body
of the rover itself.
You should be able to hear
the wheels kind of crunch
along on the sand
and on the rocks.
DALLAS TAYLOR: Who knows
what else this Mars
Rover might hear?
For now, we'll just
have to appreciate
the abundance of sound present
on our very own planet Earth.
This was an excerpt from
the podcast "Twenty Thousand
Hertz," which
explores the world's
most recognizable and
interesting sounds.
To catch the full show,
click on the links
below, and be sure to subscribe.
[MUSIC PLAYING]